- [Narrator] Bioluminescence
is the scintillating effect
of a living thing emitting light.
And, in a small coastal
town in central Japan,
one glowing creature is also a delicacy.
Toyama Bay is around 4,000 feet deep,
one of the deepest bays in all of Japan
and home to one of the
only commonly edible
bioluminescence species in the world.
- [Narrator] Firefly squid fishing
isn't a normal fishing job.
They have to fish in the dead of night.
Bioluminescence sea creatures
prefer the dark depths of the ocean.
But the firefly squid lights
up the shores when they spawn,
making them easier to catch.
- [Narrator] Where is
all that squid going?
Well, to places like Kappo Araki,
a small Japanese restaurant.
- [Narrator] Chef Araki's menu
includes multiple variants
of firefly squid: from salted
to grilled, boiled to sashimi.
All of them delicious, and,
most importantly, fresh.